bon pour le moral parce que les petits
frères des pauvres c'est très familial
et c'est convivial on les compte c'est
comme une seconde famille comme chaque
année les petits frères des pauvres de
rambouillet se sont activés pour les
fêtes de fin d'année avec la crise
sanitaire le traditionnel grand repas de
noël pour les personnes isolées a été
annulée le 23 décembre une trentaine de
bénévoles a donc livrer des colis
gourmand à domicile avec le co vie de la
cette année c'est un peu particulier
donc on leur amène toussaint un plateau
avec leur repas de noël
et puis des petits cadeaux parce qu'elle
moins deux seuls donc ce jour là et que
c'est pas très drôle donc au moins ça
leur fait un bon dîner et des petites
friandises foie gras à coquilles
saint-jacques bûche et même une petite
bouteille de vin blanc
les bénévoles ont voulu donner du baume
au coeur aux personnes isolées qu'elle
soit à domicile ou en ehpad
après sept années 2020 difficile ça a
été surtout très compliquée en début
d'année parce que nous ne pouvions pas
aller les voir à domicile donc on
faisait beaucoup par téléphone mais
beaucoup s'ennuyer deuxième confinement
nous avons pu aller les voir continuer à
les voir à domicile en prenant toutes
les précautions sanitaires voulu ce qui
a été moins dur pour elles mêmes pour
nous parce qu'on sentait quand même
qu'on leur rend des services qu'on leur
faisait plus rien au total 15 personnes
à domicile est également une quinzaine
en ehpad se sont vus offrir colis
gourmand et petits cadeaux pour les
fêtes
les petits frères des pauvres de
rambouillet aimerait recruter encore
plus de bénévoles pour faire en sorte
comme leurs devises l'indiquent que noël
ne rime plus pour nos aînés avec
isolement